okay so for folks who are joining us on
the live stream
um this is we are looking at some
details of version 12 of open language
relative to the way that the cloud
understands that functions understand
where they are being evaluated this is
not set up to be downloadable um which
is really odd how come
oh this is on the internal cloud this is
an older version yes
okay well let's let's just go to these
pages and we can we can enlarge them and
so on
all right so let's go the veneration
environment should feel hopeful is is
gonna be super straightforward okay so
the new entry is web evaluation which is
what the cloud uses for the thing that
happens when you to cloud evaluate we
had originally thought that we make it
the same as session but that's not how
the cloud works and it's also not very
useful because this is for upon short
evaluations and it's quite different
from a session but so why are we calling
it web it doesn't have anything to do
with the web I mean this is what you get
if I say cloud evaluate yes if you say
cloud evaluative dollar evaluation
environment on a modern cloud then
that's what you should get yes
yeah I don't think the reason the reason
it says web is because I mean these are
essentially web requests that are down
to the crown now this is not something I
made up the cloud has been like that and
probably not easy to change in a crowd
whoa wait wait wait wait wait but the
implementation method for cloud evaluate
so what you're saying is um
why don't we call it cloud evaluation or
I mean what really is it it's remote
cloud evaluation I mean the cloud
receives a very quest for an evaluation
and I'm not sure whether it there are
other cases where it receives such
requests so whether the only ones come
from cloud llevado
cloud evaluate okay but for example if I
were to do um cloud deploy of delayed of
dollar evaluation environment okay let's
do that
and now yes that's the other case all
right that's for API calls
that's what right next to it well I am
guessing maybe on I mean you're right
that if we had a slash eval like in a
private cloud I mean this would have to
say if we're gonna do it this way
evaluation request evaluation initiated
through an API request would be the
description I would would will want to
give them for the data API case no no
for this case this will be evaluation
initiated by an HTTP request yes but
what's the difference in an API call to
an HTTP request on this evaluation well
the cloud treats those those two
differently we these are the different
kernel pools I mean I don't know all the
details but apparently for the cloud
this is a quite an important distinction
the way these are these are handled
I mean api's probably I mean also in
terms of
it's because the baby evaluation is your
thing well um what about saying that
okay I'm beginning to agree with you
that web evaluation is okay because it's
it's the equivalent of what would happen
if there was a slash eval um
element in you know standard API for
evaluation which we will support on
private clouds but not on the public
cloud we need to find out about that um
who's coming here is a caller yes okay
so you understand the issue the issue is
in a private cloud there is just like
you can have slash object slash blah
blah blah blah blah you can also have
slash eval and then I don't know what
the code equals whatever or something
like this I see sense so we need to look
at how this is handled s right and that
should be the same evaluation
environment I mean I'm not a expert on
the cloud but now I understand I always
bring this up because I mean I just took
that value form from the cloud they told
me which learn web evaluation evaluation
that's just what what it says okay but
anyway so that this is what it should be
and maybe that's how they're doing it is
through some eval okay maybe we should
try to get is somebody here able to get
Joel um I can try to go get him okay
yeah you can tell you immediately but
okay let's go back to the agenda here um
and the next is the evaluation
environment that's the name of the
option whose value is usually taller
evaluation environment that shouldn't be
too hard
let's just go
based off of that table okay
persistent location this is a different
story
yes maybe I know I mean it's it's a
related because it's about cookie
managed international persistence which
require these evaluation environments so
you could actually initialize them
properly so I made that description of
yours that old description about service
ocean cookie managed I turned them right
so I made them no longer tentative
because they really eventually be
supported as soon as the cloud is ready
this is nothing that is dependent on
twenty point oh right isn't that a
Wolfram cookie in browsers for for for a
Bowser or something or is it be good
enough to say Watson browser cookie hmm
strange strange road go down and read
what what you wrote about it maybe it's
clear down the cookie managed moving
from persistent coconuts it I mean it's
a stand of cookie yes
yeah no okay um did we manage to find
Joel not yet
okay all right let's go back to these
other things here oh did you oh yeah
okay we are looking at dollar valuation
environment and related things and
there's this case of web evaluation
which has to do with the things that are
used for cloud evaluate and what I was
saying was that I thought that we are
heading right how I don't even know how
can evaluate works but I was supposed to
have a slash eval URL structure that
would potentially be opened on private
clouds and somehow authenticated on
public clouds what's the story with this
well I don't know about slash eval but
there's a slash of such evaluations that
you post to and that's how a lot of I
quit works and that my understanding is
that's what they used for wolfram
scripts - cloud as well I think that is
that is the end point I mean if you want
a different URL can change that but okay
okay so wait a minute what we're dealing
with is the value of dollar evaluation
environment okay so this this is used
then you know this should probably
reference cloud evaluates in my hair
maybe
okay probably also cloud deploy okay
well and also API function and so on yes
okay but and I don't know
a reference um I hear and what we're
doing there oh I see that's different
yeah okay so um okay the question is is
that named web evaluation the right name
it's I was wondering about that I mean
it's what we're using it for is
specifically cloud is there a broader
sense that this might get used in I
don't think so
I mean look look at the cases session
means the session kernel in the cloud or
a local session kernel this is the whole
point of this is it's initiated by an
HTTP request that's that's the defining
feature of this now what's the
difference between the web api and the
the web evaluation that has to do with
the difference between of kernel pools
and initializations doesn't it not quite
it's really just where do you get the
code from web evaluation is user says
here's an expression web api is go run
this object
I see otherwise we're pretty similar
okay but it's important to have two
different evaluation environments so you
can initialize them properly yes yes all
right well let's see um let's let's
write down what we just said here okay
the web api well let's see the web
evaluation environment is used by cloud
evaluate and by wolfram script - cloud
web api
my environment is used when API function
when delayed API function form function
when when code in delayed etc is
executed as a result of a web request
that fit reasonable um I don't know how
to format this that's I am that's a
question for uh I don't think we want me
to do this um Carla can you deal with
this please sure
I'm going to try typing literal input
there but I'm not sure that's right
that's the weird to courier font that's
probably also bug and doctor tool see my
report okay um okay okay all right I
think that's that um all right are we
happy with this then yes okay
um hopefully will soon be able to get
some of these things
this list is no longer this is not the
future of the day sister past don't you
see that was more or less a
brainstorming so you had different cases
like web form but low load and so on
which simply are not distinguished by
the cloud I think that's right
should we just delete this here I'm just
going to delete this yes yes we are
happy with the new list yes okay shall I
make a comment here the script
environment is used by wolfram script
for local evaluation that a useful thing
to say
if it's - yes well can somebody could
kala can you confirm that okay I know we
could try running it and see what
happens but um let's try to avoid doing
that um oh and that needs to be a link
this waffle script stuff needs to be
links okay yes up there in the list in
the table it says script run in batch
mode so there might be an issue
obviously if you just to go from script
interactively then you should get
session but yes something we need to
check yes
so okay all right let's keep going here
okay so we did persistence location now
we got expand file name yes this is a
completely different so if you open
expand file named and I can tell you
what what this is about
sure drop now um
no hang around just for me I kind of
think you can now the what on earth this
converts a URL yes that's you know we
had these my local objects are the only
part of the system that use that file
URL syntax and there's always been the
question of how do you convert them into
proper path name and since unfortunately
our file handling isn't as flexible to
just add a new syntax we thought that we
would have provide at least a couple of
functions that allow you to convert it
and the expand file name is used to
canonicalize file names so if you have
have one of these file URLs and here is
how you turn it into a naked past name
and that is the purpose of this of this
piece of code okay so if I say so what
about just overloading absolute file
name or something like that absolute try
name is a different function that checks
whether a file exists and stuff like
that we looked at that okay so I'm just
trying to understand what this does so
if I do this okay it'll do that if you
if you look at the exam you can see
examples of the use of expand funding
for you alright so here I see it seems
useful
it seems sensible this is I don't quite
understand why file of the URL doesn't
work well the Creator the dogma is that
file is an inert weapon and so it cannot
do anything ok fine I mean if you do
file of URL can't it resolved at runtime
no file doesn't do anything every
function that accepts the file wrapper
would have to test for this and invoke
code now of course nowadays we would
define a file object and the proper
class and methods and whatever
constructors and it would be a lot I
don't need to but well ok but but I mean
this this claim that the file of the URL
can't work I don't really buy that I
don't think there's anything wrong with
span father's you will have to you will
have to convince other people that files
should do something there has been very
strong resistance to this very notion
and you run into the same with URL which
also doesn't do anything well let's pick
this up in an LCC meeting yes that's
where you will hear about the kind of
resistance so yes converts URL with with
a file well ski
is the name of that No okay so I mean it
looks funny but okay look a file ski a
URL with we could say something like
this to an absolute file path yes to an
absolute found them to your of us to an
absolute file name which is what it says
up the top of their okay yeah you
couldn't activate examples please you
should do that you should do that okay
okay okay so then you say file named Joe
and I'm joined find him spit behaved
exactly the same so it's supposed to
look at those
what's this climb yeah that it works
totally curious if this was gonna say
something about that how can this say a
single argument here I don't understand
why does it say it doesn't convert it
found them join can use a URL right
that's the correct statement Wi-Fi name
join has two ways to call it one is with
that list of path names now then it also
says that finding the green one file
name join of name canonicalize is the
file name and that's the case that I'm
okay but I don't think we should even I
just don't think we should make a big
production out of that because that's a
that's a corner case of file name join
mm-hmm I mean I I wouldn't mind if you
said we shouldn't support it that's fine
we have Explo we should support it we
should have support the thing but I mean
yeah I mean file name joining one
argument is an equivalent to expand file
name yes I sure hope is Oh magnificently
ridiculous here look it doesn't even get
mentioned here so presumably this was
probably pretty done long before explain
file name is that true I don't know
that's quite possible I mean no they
were both new and seven um
does it work with those four when you
give it in the name well then there's no
more you alright tell me that's okay
that's it it's only this single to
string the string or your case but I
mean it is a bit bit a strange function
that it has these two different ways of
I think this is sort of irrelevant and I
personally suggest we deprecated that
but I don't know who uses that why that
came into being I mean we should look at
that yes so NCC or so should probably
find out whether this is actually used
and I don't understand what it means to
work with cloud objects so if you
provide it's the first thing in the list
is a cloud object then this is a way
it's a form to kind of like take a
directory for example and add paths to
it and get a cloud object back then oh
gosh well that's very unclear what yeah
no I mean that's why it's but it's okay
so we want to basically say here there's
a different case where that first
argument is a cloud object right yeah
and then what does it return it returns
a cloud object yeah so we would want to
put something in here that says
joins the name i2 gives a cloud oh hell
no joins the name I to the clip to the
specified cloud object to give
sub-directory what do we want to say
here okay
joins the name I to the specified to the
to the UM to the path in the specified
cloud object
work um I would recommend that we
duplicate this but let's talk about that
what does this do
okay so that's kind of dangerous right I
mean yeah okay components and so this
this makes a lot of sense with the file
URL it does this is fine
through a list so the list
- a list of parts of in the orbits of an
absolute file name right I mean the
result is exactly the same for cause I
mean the file fire based UI is you know
to pass just like a naked
string does no I understand that but
converts a file to a list okay where did
it say just use the same worthiness for
controllers two parts okay okay
anything else here this looks like we
got it okay the other ones are just
example stays I don't know whether we
have time for one more item related to
this
it's about authentication dollar ssh
authentication okay let's look at it i
just have a couple minutes here okay
wait a minute what are you saying here
so dollar ssh authentication which i
understand there was a discussion a
couple of days ago which garrett and you
were now convinced that we needed the
purpose of this is the following there
are a number of functions that you did
update your documentation what are those
the functions that we need yes so there
are a couple of functions that use SSH
internally and usually you want the same
authentication setting for all those
functions because ssh just seriously
speaks the correct one and you never
have to worry about which one to use so
it would be i think good example for
that paradigm of saying authentication :
aro dollar ssh authentication so you
have to set it only once that was the
reason for this for this variable um
okay we don't seem to have knitted this
variable anywhere it's not I mean it's
completely new I mean it has been and
undocumented
and the way we had to put it is in
remote connect remote one possessed
remote file at the moment it says
authentication automatic and it should
say authentication code on equals dollar
ssh authentication but i want it just to
make sure that this variable will
survive our our dogs meetings and make
it into trance point go before right we
have a question on the live stream from
brian about the file conversions and for
those file name things you know how i
mean we built those functions at a time
when there was still things like VMS
file systems that had totally wacky
specifications for files the question is
will those functions convert to the file
formats for other operating systems and
I think the answer that is unfortunately
it's really hard but maybe it's become
easier in modern times comments yeah I
mean the there's an option these these
file functions have an option operating
system but the only supported cases are
the ones that the three or four ones did
which one of these fell follow me
finally file name whoops what is it
expand file name expand finding probably
there we go this is still futurist uses
the conventions of specified operating
system possible choices to that does
that look bucks
try that thank you to a create file
tyranny to do I need to do a create file
you just won't do yeah take that tactic
take that one and two a operating system
operates not a good start that it's read
um well it seems to know something
oh so that's my future I start well but
it knew that it could have that option
okay yes I mean they see the examples
that
that know about the option is your bills
and your tasks okay listen there's a bug
here there's something wrong because
this thing knew about these options I
think that they're there but somehow it
hasn't been properly this needs to be
okay Karla we look into this okay okay
alright fine
okay let's go back to knitting let's see
we want to look where remote connectors
used okay so first of all you say in
remote connect you're saying this should
be that there should be ssh dollar ssh
other yes if if we if if we go that if
we decide to have that variable then all
i remote connect remote one remote one
process remote file all of those
I like this actually this is good okay
remote file it with Peter I think the
last one oh let's do a few choice no we
should
that is definitely in choice board oh
okay just make it
experimental okay but it has it been has
it been knitted I mean this this whole
this whole thing the SSH functions are
planned for for the next stocks meeting
which hasn't been scheduled yet because
there are still some start some things
to figure out but if we can achieve the
decision on dollars ssh authentication
that will become a lot easier okay well
I think we've agreed yes then then I
will proceed with Constantine and
Garrett and then we'll have I mean you
can if you want to have a look at your
authentication page because that's where
it all comes together where is the
identification page just authentication
it's there the name of the option and it
has its own web page no I understand
that but I'm asking about the guide page
well authentication applause so at the
moment this is a lot of blue because
this is there are two developments that
come together one is Bradleys
authentication stuff and the other is
the ssh authentication they both share
the name of the option but that's not
the problem because the keys in the
Association are our different you see
you have to secure you have B yeah okay
but we didn't need I mean the system
credential stuff on the keychain stuff
is no they're not no I mean this I mean
if you have a system credential you
don't need them authentication I mean it
will come together in the authentication
dialog that's where you specify that you
want to use the system credentials okay
all right so if we could replace the old
stuff by the salt let's not do this in
this meeting okay
I mean I know you know what I need to
know about dollar Isis a choice
education how do you prepare fine okay
so don't forget that the thing has to be
knitted okay monks okay looks good okay
and Brian our live stream is pointing
out the horrors of Windows file systems
and the fact you don't really know what
you have yeah until you're on the
machine
which is why it's hard for us to
remotely determine what the file name
might be under windows I mean I suppose
we could have some I don't even know
what the state information you need I
mean so they still have like C drives
and things some whether it is this
activity but what it is is on one hand
you have to see : drives and then you
have the mounted shares from the remote
files and those have names that start
with an arbitrary string and so I mean
these two cases are clearly
distinguished so we can even if you're
not in Windows we can do the right thing
but whether it actually exists that's a
different question because then you
would need to know whether that chair is
mounted yeah fair enough
but I mean we could we can make the
prediction and if the file isn't there
well tough luck yes I mean we can we can
do reasonable I think that would be
useful job um I mean I've certainly use
of the operating system option for
playing with my local objects because
there I need to convert these things
back and forth something it's very good
to be able so fine so let's make it real
all right I gotta run
thanks everybody see you later ok thank
you